um I'm gonna ask this
to the women oh
do you want to get married
and if you do do you think that your
wife material
oh how do you stop me I'm like I'm gonna
let someone else
do you think your wife material uh no I
don't think I'm wifey material now like
I'm not wifey material at all like with
cooking and stuff like because I live
with my parents
like someone my mother is like the the
person who's in charge of the whole
household you they she cooks and
everything so I don't think I'd be
materialistic wife now maybe in the
future yeah are you are you trying to
learn to be aware I think in the future
I would definitely try to learn but for
now I'm just like YOLO no I don't really
care about her life
I can't even crack an egg girl
but I don't care I at least I can clean
did you say you were 27.
ladies okay you're 18. do you think your
work material do you think you're worth
material so I think I'm right material
yeah uh I do think I'm white material
but I also think that that's gonna
that's quite subjective so I think men
might find white material to different
men is going to be different things they
might look for different things in a
wife do you know what I mean but if you
you're asking me if I'm wife material
I'd say yeah I think what do you think
makes you worth material
um so I think a lot of those like
feminine attributes that we spoke about
earlier so being nurturing and being
caring
um allowing yourself to be led by the
right man
um yeah and I you know I want to take
care of my man I want to take care of my
home I want to take care of my family
those are all things that I want to do
and I think those are all things that
you know you can fall under being good
wife materials so the on the video the
Filipina P shout out to the Filipina P
um so that's going to be my wife
I'm not into Filipino women but it's
just you know whatever
um she understands what it is or the
women generally in those countries it
seems that they generally understand
what it is that men want in a wife okay
um do you think you can compete
with women like that
yeah yeah yeah okay uh yes you don't
know me though so how can you say that
no I won't yeah no I wasn't talking I
was talking
you haven't seen me yeah you have kids
don't you yeah how many just two how
would you compete with a single
childless woman is she single and
childless Filipino yeah yeah yeah okay
well
material in the aspects of being fit in
your feminine and you're talking about
just Purity if that is the only standard
that we're talking about then obviously
knocks and can't yeah so I can't compete
with Purity no you know you know how
women like the the top 20 over six Foods
x amount of money do you know the top 20
for men if they had the choice and the
option to do do you know what those that
that category of women will be no
children it'll be a single virgin woman
that's pretty much the top one or two
percent I'm not struggling but what I
mean is I'm sure you'll be fine there's
this simps everywhere but
thank you
shots fired shots
that is above average still like
somebody else yeah of course of course
but what I mean is that that is the top
20 for men is that single attractive
thin woman that's what we're all aiming
for now some of us fall uh you know
basically we settle uh for simping or
whatever else but I promise you that as
much as if you go with a five foot six
or five foot eight man who's earning 40
000 pounds a year and you're settling
for if a man is going with a woman who's
had two children he is settling yeah
that's okay
it's really difficult to find like I
think it would be difficult to find
someone when you've got two kids and
you're a single mother I mean
think of it from the guy's perspective
it's difficult to find yeah
mum I found a girl but I'm 35. no but
just say he says Mama found a girl oh
really son you found a girl yeah who is
she this girl she's got two kids
all right let's say even if your son's
let's say your son is 40 now okay well
if he's 40 then if he loves him
it's not mine it's not mine wait wait
wait because didn't he behind us say
that there's different pools right so if
your son's wife your son's 40. you would
think his first choice should be someone
with kids well what if he had biparts
so what's wrong with him why doesn't he
even if he even if he does even even
okay even if he had kids why would he
pick a woman with kids over a woman
without like this shouldn't well because
if she doesn't have children if she
doesn't have children she may not have a
level of understanding that he might
need for him having his children over in
the house and all of these different
elements that go into having a child
even if you're a man if you're looking
after if you're co-parenting you're
gonna have them children on your own if
you've got a woman that's going to want
your undivided attention and you're not
able to give it that might give it he
don't understand men like when you say
that I hear it because you're speaking
from a woman's perspective well I can
only do that yeah of course but you
don't but as a man and as men here we
know that if we're going to pick a woman
for our long-term part
we're not trying to find some single
moment yeah I mean Sarah you you have a
son I have a son and I understand that a
lot of women would negate me because I
haven't because I have a son yeah
because I've probably got quote unquote
baggage that I could be bringing with me
right so I understand your mama drama
baby mama drama whatever it is right and
I understand that but yeah and I
understand that I'm not every woman's
First Choice a lot of the time
single mothers don't understand they're
not men's first choice I understand that
but I also think like you're kind of
were you guys
even when I ask you a simple question
like I'll say okay if he's 40 and he who
should his first choice be you guys will
still not give it to him
my genuine answers
no I don't I just think it's not honest
well that is my honest I wouldn't say
I've been honest in every other element
if my son was 40 and he met somebody who
he truly loved and was and had children
and she had and she had children that
should be his first choice
as his mother it's not my job to tell
him what to do at 40 years old
because he raised this man yeah
yeah and him he should be able to make a
I if I haven't done my job good enough
today at 40 years old he can't make a
decision on his own he needs to come to
Mummy to ask him
as well can I just interject with a more
realistic scenario which in fact um
every day
um but sign language but as far as a
real situation which actually I know
someone who exactly in this position
there were 27 28 with a
brilliant business really successful
already had two houses married a woman a
single mother at 37. would you allow
yourself how old was my he was the
person I know was twenty yeah
a single mother well how am I allowing
right you're saying allowing as if I
have control no no but what I mean is
would you be
yeah well with with her kids are you
gonna want her to uh are you going to
tell your son yeah bring go on bring the
girl home are you gonna 100 100 if my
son is happy and he comes home to me and
say mum this is the woman that I love
and I am going to marry her and these
are 100 who am I to tell him oh yeah
right I do agree and I'm very I'm very
nurturing so I love babies but as his
mother as his mother as his mother your
opinion matters
okay let me finish let me femininity
isn't cutting me off so it's like as you
as his mother your opinion matters right
and so it's like you could say oh son I
don't think that's maybe a good idea or
you would say it's a good idea
why would he come home and ask for my
opinion though because he values
do you go home every time you get in a
relationship do you go home and ask your
market I'll I'll say this when I got
with
I was in a previous relationship for 10
years right and I got with a single
mother and when I never had any children
right and I I specifically remember my
mom saying
I don't know son this might not be the
one but I know you say you love her but
I don't know and the thing is my mom
turned out to be right
but also because my mom as a woman of
age who's already had her children she
could foresee the future that I couldn't
see I'm in love Mama love this woman
yeah I'm great she's thinking uh down
the road son there was no red pill there
was no manosphere to help me out when I
was in that situation I just had my mum
and and I didn't listen to her do I wish
that I would have hell [__] yeah
because my mom had a had an insight and
a wisdom that I didn't have so as a
mother you have an insight and a wisdom
that your son doesn't have so what so
when your son comes to you
in his 20s or whatever and says Mom I
found a woman and you know she's got
children and you are you literally gonna
be like yeah yeah son that's the one oh
you're gonna children
yeah come on
foreign
yeah and I think there's a difference
between sitting your son down and being
like son you haven't got kids yet she's
got kids are you sure about this yeah
with this are you ready for this I think
there's a difference between having that
conversation and being like Oh my God no
no no this is wrong you should go you
said you're what 37 two children
would you let if you because you know
yourself yeah would you let your son
Choose You
um a woman just like you two children 37
and he's in his would you let your son
choose a woman just like I would
probably say no because I just wouldn't
want to put that pressure on someone
that's 27 right for me I just wouldn't
feel comfortable being with someone at
27 and I'm just saying like I've got
this comes with a lot of responsibility
we're probably different life stages you
know what I'm saying so for me it's
probably going to be a no and that's
what I'm saying I would have that
conversation with my son but ultimately
it's his decision
of course yeah so I would have that
conversation you've given some advice
yeah I've given some advice and like you
said there's that foresight that insight
there yeah because you've got it right
exactly but I just think if he doesn't
have kids like it doesn't matter how
nice she is like I would tell them to
not deal with her because she's got kids
I would say just like yeah like and it's
just it's not personal it's just like
that's a lot of that's a lot of
responsibility yeah exactly and you
didn't make that decision and you're
going to be the one responsible for it
I'm gonna I'm gonna be a little bit
crude but um yeah I mean the person that
I that I'm talking about they eventually
got divorced and uh they did he does
have a daughter from from that marriage
but um generally I saw it coming and my
advice was straight up pumping up mate
pump and dump as men you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want
to sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible